so who's my guest this week the last
afghan women's minister hasina safik
afghanistan the 1970s an era of hope for
women
as the 80s started my guests turned five
and everything changed
over time freedoms and education were
rolled back
violence and humiliation commonplace
she and her family escaped and as the
years passed she dedicated herself in
exile to campaigning for women's rights
as democracy returned to afghanistan so
did she eventually appointed to run the
ministry of women's affairs under the
last afghan government only to have to
escape again last august as the taliban
regained power
ever since she's been living with her
family as a refugee in a london hotel
this interview is going to give you a
remarkably powerful account of what it
was like to flee the taliban here's
what's coming up i had nothing to feel
i was not even concerned
about what will happen
to me
i was so concerned with the big
big big group of people that i was
seeing there
what have we done
that we are facing this time
so it's it's very different i really
forgot the time living
when i was eating i was crying because i
thought that
i'm eating but there are many people who
are not eating there
why should i eat
[Music]
why should i live
i couldn't help any women back there
christina thank you so much for joining
us welcome to the programme
thank you very much for the opportunity
i've wanted to start by saying
do you worry that the world has
forgotten a bit about afghanistan at the
moment
what i see today is and there is a very
total uncertainty
globally
about what to do
whereas the world has forgotten
that there was a 20 years of investment
on the human resources of afghanistan so
there is always a hope
and an approach to move forward they
have forgotten but there are many
opportunities if they just dig out
about or within their surroundings
how are the people that you're talking
to
as you say left alone under the taliban
uh i think basically and there is still
a lot of fear there is a lot of
uncertainty there is a lot of
hopelessness because
uh
and also insecurity
so the people really do not know because
almost every week there is a new news
and instead of the situation getting
better
uh or the situation becoming hopeful
it's becoming deteriorating
starting from the day one
where stopping women for going to
offices
abolishment of women ministry the same
thing stopping of women organizations
and asking the women who were in
leadership positions those who were
still in afghanistan to stay back home
and many other things so day by day
there is not a concrete or tangible
indicator or directive through which you
can see that there is a space or a place
for the women of afghanistan or for
their future but it but it also if i may
say with these reports of girls getting
ready to go back into school so excited
really looking forward to being able to
go back in the boys have been let back
in yes the girls have not but on the
actual day they were expected to go in
yes there is a u-turn they don't let
them in everyone is shocked why
is it a sin to be a girl
in such
such or in a certain location no it's
not so what is it
it's a country it's a structure
there are many many big things to think
about
why is
a women's scarf a woman's dress a
women's school why is this an agenda
there are many national priorities to
move forward for nation building for the
development of the country
why
is this the first priority at this
critical situation why do you think it
is knowing what you know of the taliban
having lived through the time that
you've been it i think there is no clear
vision
there is no clear structure
there is no governance policy
there has been a big investment on the
education of women generally education
and then specifically on women and girls
in the last 20 years
so for me not only the present de facto
government but also the international
community
shall be accountable because they have
invested invested so much in education
and health
why are they just becoming only
the people who are listening
why there is no intervention
where is the mutual accountability why
are we not talking
we are all
related to each other
as the basis of humanity as the basis of
investment in the last 20 years do you
think that women will get an education
that women will be allowed back into
their jobs what are your levels of hope
like at the moment
uh well presently from the situation
that i see about the prison structure in
afghanistan i'm totally hopeless
because day after day
what's the you you hear things
that you can't even imagine
why would the girls not go to school
even if there is no resources
where are the commitments why for
example we heard that
the teachers and the doctors are getting
their pay
so why are they getting the pay if the
children are not going to school so
there should be a very clear definition
a very clear structure of what they want
to do
so that is why it is really
hopeless
in prison situation in afghanistan
but on the whole
the world is there to help each other
this is the time for the world to think
about the people of afghanistan to think
about the women of afghanistan to take
your mind back if i may to what happened
in august i mean much has been made
about how chaotic the evacuation was i
think there was not a proper plan
there was not a proper plan for the way
it was proceeded
the decision was taken plans could be
done
plans could be made
discussions could be made on an ad hoc
urgent basis but they did not happen
that is why
today still there are many many
people
who need to be evacuated they are stuck
they are back in afghanistan whose lives
are real in danger
because they helped the west and now
they're on a list with the taliban
because they helped the west but they
helped the humanity yes they wanted to
live generally but i mean that's how
they would be viewed by the taliban
potentially that's why you're exactly in
danger
exactly
so they are still stuck in afghanistan
that is why
whenever i'm talking i'm basically
suggesting for the world on three
basic or fundamental issues the first
one is urgent action
on humanitarian and protection of those
people who really invested their lives
forward for the success of the
international
donation or help or support the second
thing is the midterm solution for me as
a woman the caretaker has no vision for
women
as a woman and we can never ignore women
especially in a country like afghanistan
where the majority of population are
are women and the third thing is
the definition of the international
relation with afghanistan the
international community should really
sit together
and
based on
their priorities they have to match up
the prison situation of afghanistan for
a reason which is help and support the
humanity the people and the women of
beyond financial aid exactly because of
course
that has been the way that afghanistan
has just about avoided famine because of
the levels of donation food aid on that
front but you're talking about actually
intervening exactly
how did you actually escape
uh emma to be honest i was not planning
to leave really yes
my plan was that i cannot leave because
there are so many women who need me here
but after that i saw that the situation
was deteriorating and some of my close
friends suggested that your life is
valuable for us
i had worked a lot with the
british
organizations in foreign ministry
and i really don't know how i wrote the
email
i did not know who to contact but i
wrote the email and the contacts which i
had
and then i think after
two days
and definitely coordination of the
international sisters who had made
an informal group to save the lives of
women especially the women who were in
decision making positions
uh they were in constant contact they
were telling me you will get an email
you will get an email and almost every
second they would say did you get an
email did you get an email and then
after when i received the email from
them
that you have to come to
baron hotel
in 12 hours
i did not know where baron hotel was
that's in afghanistan yes yes
i did not have any vehicles so i message
them back
not the
email address but the group of women who
were helping me i told them i have no
vehicles nothing to go
so can you arrange for the vehicles they
told me we will try so they arranged
once and then i think there were some
security issues they cancelled it
because
like i never was assuming this situation
so that is why
and i was a role model to many people
because i also believe in a
balanced life so i i was a lot in public
everyone knew me shopkeepers everyone
knew me
that is why there was a lot of security
issues on those days
one of the other female
minister former minister she called me
and she gave me the number who had
helped her
so uh and they were demanding for some
financial
like rent
so i got my son's piggy bank where we
were all the time and his birthday we
were giving him and we
broke that and we had some money which
we could give the
logistic company or the people who
we did not go through the formal airport
because it was too crowded
someone told us that you can go from
behind the drivers they guided us
we went there
the family was with me
they told me to go in but when i went
there it was a terrible situation there
was a lot of fire guns there was a lot
of
lashing they were lashing people
some of the family got lashes
the taliban yes we're doing this yes yes
and some of your some of your family
the family members receive lashes and
then i decided that no way because they
were also gunfiring and i said
if something happens to them and i'm
alive i will never
live with that kill so we decided me and
my husband that we will go back home
whatever happened on the way i was on
half of the way when my friend the
former minister
she called me and she she scolded me in
fact she said don't do this mistake
you have to come there is a a very um
a canal where the suicide attack
happened two days after
so she said we also came from that way i
said i cannot go because
my family is with me and i had a elderly
sick mother
she said no whatever you do if you go
back you i know you will not be alive
and then when i went there there was a
big crowd going up going down going up
i think maybe 1 000 or 800 people were
there
so we came up
finally we came and
i called
a number
i don't know it's maybe destiny or god
helped us
the number went through and it was one
of my
female friends who were organizing this
and i called her and i said i don't know
what to do
i'm in here in the crowd i'm
on the top of that dirty ditch
with the family what to do so you're
standing with with all of your family
there's a lot of people around i'm just
trying to picture this yes and you're
you're at the top of a ditch you say yes
yes
you're ringing someone to try and find
out how you can leave afghanistan
yes
how are you feeling at this time that
you've got elderly family with you
you've got your children
and that's why i am i told you that i
really did not understand
that
what was all the struggle that i did in
the last 20 years
it was the second time that i had to
leave my country i left my country when
i was five years old
when russian invaded afghanistan
in with from
five years old till 25
i struggle with each drop of my blood to
go back
invest my
my my knowledge invest my talent
for my coming generations so that they
do not feel
and i really was killed on that night
emma
i had nothing to feel
i had no feelings
my only concern i was not even concerned
about what will happen
to me
i was so concerned with the big
big big group of people that i was
seeing there
people were sitting with their papers
passports
everything and they were saying oh i
have worked with this oh i have and i
was like how helpless we are
who have what have we done
that we are facing this this this this
time so
that is why it was it was really like
to be very honest i could not feel
anything till one month
i was all the time crying in the middle
of the night i was sweating i was waking
up
and i was thinking someone is knocking
the door or there is something happening
outside
there are some
some of their own voices or whatever
they were doing
so it's it's very different very
different i cannot i really forgot the
time living
when i was eating i was crying because i
thought that
i'm eating but there are many people who
are not eating there
why should i eat
why should i live
i couldn't help any women back there
because i'm sorry
still it's like that
it's difficult
it's very difficult
i think even just that moment that you
described where you have to be with your
family and you've got to think about
them and being safe but you have such a
duty to your people and to your country
even then
i tried to help but
i was helpless i couldn't help myself
i couldn't help anyone
so it's it's it's very difficult
and then after that
the soldier told us you are you're safe
now and then they took us inside the
airport
because no one
because we left that place so
he did not know where to take us so i
showed the paper and then he took us to
the
that ground where the planes were
departing they were sitting and
departing
i think maybe for three or five hours we
were there
there were the big space
planes they were leaving
all of a sudden i saw that
there was it was written royal space
and i told the soldier that can you show
this uh
paper
to
that commander he said i'm not allowed
to i said okay
if you're not allowed i will stay here
no problem
i have been constantly asking him
about how long should we stay he said we
don't know
and then i think it was around one
o'clock at 1am
and that
the soldier went but he came back
he said i will take the paper so he took
the paper to that uk uh soldier
commander i think then he took the paper
he did that and he took that to inside
the plane maybe there were some other
and then they
waved to us and after that
we came we entered the bus and they said
that you are in safe hands now
and we were all crying him on that time
we even didn't know how to hug each
other
so it was a difficult time
and then after that we came to the uk
base
and from that onwards i think
as a human being i have to recognize
that
that it was all care in humanity
for everyone there was no special
there was no prioritization
but they were just treating everyone i
know how hard and difficult it must be
for them they have been in constant work
as a person you're still with your
family as i understand it in a hotel in
the uk yes and it's about seven months
or so now that you will have been
in this accommodation
how has that been i you know we're
thinking a lot about how many people are
displaced at the moment around the world
yes this is the second time that you've
done this but how has it been for your
family and you living in the hotel
actually to be very honest emma uh they
are they were very concerned about my
life
so none of them have been telling me
anything
but from what i see
they are hiding their feelings because
of me because they know
that i'm very very
concerned about the people back there
when you say that you mean your family
yes
i know it's difficult for them it's very
difficult because a home is a home
and a hotel is a hotel
we are getting everything there is food
there is
rooms there is internet but definitely
if it's home all the time we say home
sweet home
so home is always sweet
but they haven't been saying anything
about that because
whenever they
how i understand that uh
they are concerned is
whenever say they say they say oh we are
blessed that you are alive so that is
what
on that time i analyzed that they must
be missing
home they must be missing their home
they must be missing home here
do you think you can build a life in the
uk
of course i can because
i believe in humanity
and the reason that today
i'm here
is
basically
the human belief that i have
and that is why i
again stress on humanity on connection
on relation on confidence because it's
nothing else
but the high value
of
those friends who really believed and
worked with me as a human
i did not ask them really they asked me
at the beginning haseena how are you
haseena are you fine haseena are you
okay haseena good morning how are you
did you eat did you
so there is no policy or anything in
here it's just a real connection of
humanity
i'm very confident that i can do that
do you think you will ever be able to go
back
again and live in afghanistan
yes you do yes because i'm
i'm a very hopeful person i'm a very
positive person i will have challenges
we will have challenges but i know that
struggle brings result and i will
struggle to bring the result so that is
why i am hopeful but i need to struggle
devil and triple
to really get to those who need me
i see that safety thank you so much for
talking to me
thank you very much
and thank you to you for being with us
and listening to that remarkable
conversation
until we meet again do take care and
goodbye
[Music]
you